[Music]
happy halloween weekend one and all
welcome to fun fun fun i am your host
michael g kumar
and tonight on a very special edition
the halloween gambit edition i will be
playing miss emily for 100
cash
if she wins she takes it all
if she draws we will play another if she
dares
and it's a game in five minutes
let's have some fun
[Applause]
hey guys what you doing we're watching
prepping
this is secret prep don't lick it like
you guys have leaked everything else
don't do it blur the screen
mike you're going down
dead he doesn't know about the c6 line
don't lick it don't leak it that's our
prep good luck
today it
you think you're gonna win this you
really think you're gonna win this well
i'll give you every chance in the world
i'm gonna play the worst gambit in
television history in chess history
it'll go e4
e5
knight f3
knight c3
all right and now it's gonna shock you
just so you know if you make an illegal
move you run out of time
it's all over it's touch move okay
all right so i'm gonna
take this
good move good move and now you can
start me up
[Music]
my hundred dollars is looking pretty
secure pretty secure we're already i'm
already up apart
i like it i like it i like it i can give
you a check i could give you a check but
i don't want to
[Music]
i could
monica he's on the 100 online
could give you a check
all right i'll give you a check you
talked me into it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's just show up the
position
castle
always announced castle
all right back it up back it up back it
up
take take take take all right let's
go
oh
no i wouldn't do that to you
unless you really want me to do it mike
do it to do
he'll do anything to save that hundred
bucks danny you need a you need a
t-shirt no mercy right because i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna show you no mercy
raspberry knows
let me get away with that
danny how do you feel about the fact
that emily just gave him a take back
essentially
she didn't even need him to beat him
any other way
not yet that confident
it's too easy
this is yeah
[Music]
oh
oh
in check i'm in check
and another check
beach
[Music]
what to do what to do
the camera sees it all
you you you yeah
[Laughter]
couldn't that all yours trash could have
been
[Applause]
this was not right
you want a rematch yes that hold on that
wasn't in the contract i don't care you
did give cummer a take back so in good
sportsmanship
comer as today's arbiter or at least
witness to this catastrophe will you
give emily a rematch you're asking me
you're asking me be a good sportsman
comer
all right
for the fans for the fans i'll beat her
again for the fans all right let's do it
round two
all right you know the rules e4 e5
knight f3
[Music]
right so it's on me right
all right
try it again
work good the first time
hopefully it will work again
[Music]
that was your strategy danny just
attacked the piece back right away
you don't give private lessons anymore
in the club do you
exactly
[Music]
i'll give you a check
if there wasn't for the check there i
was almost gonna play right there
but maybe it's still okay move but
[Music]
there will be no rematch
see what's going on see what is going on
push the phone
check
legal moves do end the game and you do
have a dark square bishop so maybe i
gotta get my arm
get my king into a black
[Music]
oh
god i gotta secure the 100 now
[Music]
hmm
you don't want that
or maybe you do hey if you're gonna
stale me
we will actually replay the game just
all right the hundred dollars is
officially secured there will be
no
rematch thank you everybody for joining
into the food food food danny you're
fine all right good job
all right you can get down now mike
here
perfect